a particle moves along the curve XY
equals 16 so that the y-coordinate is
increasing we underline this the
y-coordinate is increasing at a constant
rate of 2 units per minute that means
that the rate of change of Y with
respect to T is equal to 2 what is the
magnitude in units per minute of the
particles velocity vector when the
particle is at the point 4 comma 4 so
when X is 4 and Y is 4 so let's see
what's going on
so let's first just remind ourselves
what a velocity vector what the velocity
vector will look like so our velocity is
going to be a function of time and it's
going to have two components it's going
to be what is the rate of change in the
X direction and the rate of change in
the Y direction so the rate of change in
the x direction is going to be DX DT and
the rate of change in the Y direction is
going to be dy DT and they tell us that
this is that dy DT is a constant 2 units
per minute but they're not even just
asking us for just the velocity vector
for its components they're asking for
the magnitude they're asking for the
magnitude of the particles velocity
vector well if I have some vector let me
do a little bit of an aside here if I
have some vector let's say a that is it
has components I don't know B and C well
then the magnitude of my vectors
sometimes you'll see it written like
that sometimes you'll see it written
with double bars like that the magnitude
of my vector and this comes straight out
of the Pythagorean theorem this is going
to be the square root of B squared plus
C squared the square root of the X
component squared plus the Y component
squared so if we want to know the
magnitude of our velocity vector the
magnitude of the particles velocity
vector well I could write that as the
magnitude of V and I could even write it
as a function of T it's going to be
equal to the square root of the X
component squared so that's the rate of
change of X with respect to time square
plus plus the y-component squared which
in this case is the rate of change of Y
with respect to T squared so how do we
figure out these how do we figure out
these two things well we already know
the rate of change of Y with respect to
T they say that's a constant rate of two
units per minute so we already know that
this is going to be 2 or that this whole
thing right over here is going to be 4
but how do we figure out the rate of
change of X with respect to T well we
could we could take our original
original equation that describes the
curve we could take the derivative of
both sides with respect to T and then
that's going to give us an equation that
involves X Y and then DX DT and dy DT so
let's do that so we have x y is equal to
16 I'm gonna take the derivative with
respect to T of both sides let me do
that in a different color just for a
little bit of variety so a derivative
with respect to T of the left hand side
derivative with respect to T of the
right hand side now the left hand side
we view this as the product of two
functions if we say look X is a function
of T and Y is also a function of T this
is we're gonna do a little bit of the
product rule a little bit of the chain
rule here and so this is going to be
equal to derivative of derivative of the
first function which is so we'll first
say the derivative of X with respect to
X is 1 times the derivative of X with
respect to T remember we're taking the
derivative with respect to T not with
respect to x times the second function
so x times the second function so times
y times y plus the first function which
is just x times the derivative of the
second function with respect to t so
first what's the derivative of Y with
respect to Y well that's just 1 and then
what's the derivative of Y with respect
to T
well that's dy DT and that is going to
be equal to that is going to be equal to
derivative of a constant is just zero so
let's see what does this simplify to
this simplifies to in fact we don't even
have to simplify it more we can actually
plug in the values to solve for DX DT we
know that dy DT is a constant - and we
want the magnitude of the particles
velocity vector when the particle is at
the point 4 comma 4 so when X is equal
to 4 so when X is equal to 4 and Y is
equal to 4 and Y is equal to 4 so now
it's a little messy right now but this
right here is an equation that we can
solve for there's only one unknown here
the rate of change of X with respect to
T right when we are at the point 4 comma
4 and so if we're able to figure that
out we could substitute that in here and
figure out the hole the magnitude of our
velocity vector so let us write it out
so this gives us 4 for DX DT plus what
is this 4 times 2 plus 8 is equal to 0
and so we have 4 DX DT is equal to
negative 8 - subtracting 8 from both
sides divide both sides by 4 you get DX
DT let me scroll down is equal to
negative 2 so when all the stuff is
going on the rate of change of X with
respect to T is negative 2 and so then
you square it you get a 4 right over
here and so the magnitude of our
velocity vector is going to be equal to
equal to the square root of 4 plus 4
which is equal to 8 which is the same
thing as 4 times 2 so this is going to
be 2 square roots of 2 units per minute
so that's the magnitude of the velocity
vector